it's topical questions and we will now
move on to the next item of business and
the next item of business is a statement
by Hamza Yusuf on our priorities for
Scotland the first Minister will take
questions at the end of a statement and
so there should be no interventions or
interruptions I call on Hamza Yusuf
first Minister up to 20 minutes please
thank you the presiding officer just a
few weeks ago I couldn't have imagined
that I'd be standing here as first
Minister selling out the policy
priorities and indeed the defining
missions of the government that I lead
being first minister is of course not
without its challenges it's fair to see
but not to withstanding that
no we're standing there is of course the
honor of my life and in my very first
speech to this chamber after the result
was announced I made it clear that the
people of Scotland's priorities will of
course be my priorities too and I've
been clear from the outset that I intend
on governing in the interests of the
whole of Scotland and I hope that
today's policy perspectives that has
been published is a demonstration of
that and setting out our course for the
next three years we are acknowledging as
we must that Scotland faces genuinely
difficult challenges our economy and our
public services are still recovering
from a global pandemic we're in the
midst of a cost crisis made worse of
course by the UK government's economic
mismanagement which is harming people
and hurting businesses right across the
country and we need to play our part in
addressing the global crises of climate
change and indeed nature loss and we are
also and this is worth stressing facing
the most difficult public spending
environment that is this devolved
Parliament has clearly ever seen the
inflationary shocks created by a hard
brexit a global pandemic the war in
Ukraine disastrous decisions taken as
part of the UK government's many budget
they've all placed great pressure on the
public finances our ability to deal with
that pressure that is being constrained
by UK government spending decisions and
of course a lack of borrowing powers in
fact the cost to Scotland of Westminster
control the cost of not being
independent has never been clear UK
living standards have stagnated for 15
years and did the fall and living
standards this year and the next is
expected to be the largest on record
according to the IMF the UK is to be
amongst the worst performing of any
major economy this year and the
disastrous impact of brexit supported of
course by both attorneys and labor is
biting hard and as a result we have to
make really tough decisions about our
priorities and I will be Unapologetic
about making those difficult decisions
to ensure we free up money we free up
resource to Target to those who are in
the greatest need and where we can will
go even further within the constraints
of devolution where we can go further I
absolutely will but for all the
significant challenges we face and they
are significant we also know that we can
build on the important successes
Scotland currently outperforms the UK on
unemployment rate with the unemployment
rate for men over 16 at the lowest on
record NHS waiting times are Court
backlogs improving following the
pandemic and despite the spending the
public spending climate we have expanded
free child care provision and introduced
the game-changing Scottish child payment
and of course Scotland continues to have
a highly skilled Workforce world-class
universities and colleges and huge
potential and some of the key economic
sectors of the future
the Scottish government is today
publishing their policy perspectives new
leadership a fresh start for Scotland
which will set out how this government
the government I lead will address our
challenges build on the successes of the
past but also capitalize on our
strengths it sets out the key aims the
key deliverables we intend to achieve in
each cabinet secretary's portfolio
working constructively of course with
our green party colleagues throughout
the next three years we will report
routinely regularly and transparently on
our performance against these aims and
against these outcomes the report also
emphasizes this government's work will
be defined by three distinct and
interdependent missions those missions
centered on the principles of equality
opportunity and Community require us to
tackle poverty to build a fair green and
indeed a growing economy and to improve
our Public Services there will be
Central to our efforts over the next
three years to improve the lives of the
people of Scotland
the first mission based on equality is
that we will continue to tackle tackle
poverty in all of its forms and that we
will substantially reduce child poverty
in particular an immediate Focus
inevitably will be on protecting people
as far as we possibly can from the harm
inflicted by the UK government policies
and the ongoing cost of living crisis
that means that we will often choose to
Target spending so that will benefit
those who need it the most that's one
reason why the very first action I
undertook as first Minister was to
increase the fuel in Security fund to 30
million pounds over the next three years
we'll also invest a further 1.3 billion
pounds in the Scottish child payment we
will further develop our social security
system and ensure it continues to treat
people with dignity with fairness and
respect we will expand the provision of
free School meals we'll reduce the
number of children who go into care will
keep our promise to those who are care
experience and will work to ensure that
drug deaths reduce over the next three
years and we recognize just how crucial
housing is to our aspirations of a
fairer country we'll continue to work
with local government to reduce the
number of people living in temporary
accommodation and subject of course to
the will of this Parliament be
religiously to secure a new deal for
tenants and to introduce duties to
prevent homelessness
we'll invest to make homes and buildings
Greener and we'll continue to deliver
affordable homes the majority of which
will be for social rent in all parts of
our country we'll also publish an action
plan for housing and remote Rural and
Island areas I can confirm today that
this plan will include up to 25 million
pounds from our affordable homes budget
to allow suitable properties including
empty homes to be purchased or indeed
long leased and turned into affordable
homes for key workers and others we'll
also engage with the public to explore
how best we can use our existing
taxation powers to deliver the most
progressive taxation system in the UK
and achieve the government's three
missions which I talked to today
Scotland is a wealthy country but that
wealth is not distributed evenly to
tackle poverty we need to be even Bolder
on Taxation and the redistribution of
wealth that is why I will convene an
anti-poverty Summit inviting a experts
academics anti-poverty campaigners those
with lived experience I'll also invite
of course opposition colleagues as I
believe tackling poverty is a shared
priority for us all we'll continue to
support equality inclusion and human
rights too we will Implement more of the
recommendations of the national advisory
Council on women and girls
setting officer I take great pride in
being the first first Minister from an
ethnic minority background I know my
rights are very much interdependent on
the rights of others the government I
lead will not only protect the rights of
minorities where possible we will also
Advance them particularly for those that
are the most marginalized in our society
during the Parliamentary term we will
bring forward a Human Rights bill to
incorporate within the limit limits of
course of our devolved competence
International standards on Econo
economic social cultural and
environmental rights
that is of course in stock interest
start contrast I should say It's a UK
government that pursues divisive
immigration policies at risks denying
Sanctuary to people during their hour of
need we will continue to support those
who come to Scotland fleeing war and
indeed fleeing persecution and we'll
continue to support the many thousands
of people who have come from Ukraine
during the last year for as long as
Scotland is their home they will be
welcomed here and they will be supported
presenting officer through these actions
and many more we will make significant
progress towards making Scotland a
fairer country during the next three
years
however we know that our ambition to
make Scotland fairer must go hand in
hand with our work to make Scotland more
prosperous that's why the Second
National mission is based on the
principle of opportunity using all of
the powers we have to their maximum
effect
to support economic growth for a purpose
to help businesses in trade to thrive
and to maximize the opportunity for a
fair green economy a crucial part of
this is about making a just transition
to Net Zero we will never do to oil and
gas workers in the northeast of Scotland
what Thatcher did to our Mining and
steel communities we will take the
workers of the Northeast
we will take the workers of the
Northeast and indeed the whole of
Scotland with us on our just transition
Journey we will harness the huge
potential of the green economy in
Scotland the Scotland program on its own
for example offers the potential of 28
billion pounds of supply chain work
based in Scotland a renewable energy
resources will also help us to develop a
new hydrogen sector which is why a focus
for the next three years is to lay the
foundations for a hydrogen supply chain
in Scotland excuse me we will also
continue to support Innovation and
Entrepreneurship through policies such
as our investment in new tech scalar
hubs we hope to make Scotland one of the
leading nations in Europe for business
startups we will also develop centers of
excellence for sectors such as green
technologies health and Life Sciences
digital industry and advanced
Manufacturing and as we do this we will
seek to support economic growth and
ensure that wealth is far more evenly
distributed so we will continue to
invest in skills so that people are able
to take advantage of New Opportunities
will encourage growth in every part of
Scotland by working with local and
Regional partners in setting out our
plans for the economy I also want to
make a broader point about the
government government's relationship
with our business Community
representative officer I'm the proud son
of a business owner in fact just this
month my dad's business turned 40 years
old and despite our family efforts to
the country Mr Yusuf senior has no plans
to retire just yet but businesses and
small businesses in particular are the
backbone of our economy and government
support for business is essential for
the delivery of a well-being economy we
need businesses to grow to create those
good well-paying jobs that will enable
us to reinvest in initiatives to
eradicate poverty we also rely on
businesses and of course their workers
to pay taxes that are public services
rely on that's why there has never been
a conflict to my mind between supporting
our economy to grow in line with our Net
Zero Ambitions and introducing policies
such a progressive taxation which
enables us to reduce poverty both go
hand in hand as part of that well-being
economy many of us support
we also need some government regulation
of business the business community
community itself recognizes then
unrestricted Market is incompatible with
the well-being of our people our
communities and of course our
environment but the balance here needs
to be right a number of business
organizations have expressed concern in
recent months about the balance that the
Scottish government has been striking in
fact they have called for a reset of the
relationship between business and
government and I'm happy to start that
reset today and I want to do so by
confirming three specific steps the
first relates to the deposit return
scheme I remain committed to the scheme
as a way to increase recycling to reduce
litter on our streets and our beaches
and help achieve our Net Zero Ambitions
but we recognize the uncertainty that
continues to be created as a result of
course of the UK government delaying the
decision to exclude this scheme from the
internal Market Act of course we had
talked for a decision on that this week
but has not come at the same time I in
the circular economy Minister have heard
the concerns of business particularly
about the schemes Readiness for launch
this August and as a result we will now
delay the launch of the scheme to the
first of March 2024.
that's um please guys go to Universal
support around the chamber this provides
10 months for businesses to get ready
we'll use that additional time of course
to work with business and circularity
Scotland to address the concerns with
this excuse me I I had given a bit of
latitude but it is getting quite noisy
they are really excited about the policy
perspective that I'm bringing forward to
this chamber today
it's not a problem
I've always said I've always said that I
will reach across the place called
divide uh where necessary we will use
that additional time of course to work
with businesses and circularity Scotland
to address concerns with the scheme and
ensure a successful launch next year
we've also developed a package of
measures to simplify and de-risk the
schema to support small businesses and
Hospitality in particular and the
circular economy minister of course will
provide further details to Parliament
this week on this package of the new
timetable and our engagement with the UK
government over the critical decisions
now that we need them to make to allow
the scheme to proceed to proceed in
terms of that exemption of the internal
Market act the Second Step relates to
the Scottish government's consultation
on restrictions to alcohol advertising
the aim of this consultation to reduce
the harm caused by alcohol to children
it's not just admirable it's one that I
support wholehearted
but it's clear that some of the
proposals have caused real concern to
the industry which is already facing
challenges on multiple fronts and
therefore instructed my officials to
take these ideas back to the drawing
board work with industry and of course
crucially Public Health stakeholders to
agree a new set of proposals I believe
that all of us want to reduce the harm
caused by alcohol particularly to young
people but without undermining
Scotland's world-class drinks industry
or tourism tourism sector I'm hopeful
that by taking a fresh look at this
issue we can find our way forward which
achieves both of these crucial aims
finally I've written to key business
representative groups and ask them to
engage in Urgent discussions with the
Scottish government to agree a new deal
for Scottish businesses these
discussions will be chaired jointly by
the cabinet secretary for the well-being
economy and the representative of the
business sector
discussions we'll explore amongst other
things how government can beg to support
our businesses and communities using the
policy levers we do have including
non-domestic rates I've asked the
co-chairs to report back to me with
initial thoughts this summer these three
steps with uh all I trust will be
welcomed individually by Scotland's
business Community but I hope that
collectively they also send a broader
signal about this government's approach
to business this government knows that
Scotland can only be successful if our
businesses are successful and so as
first Minister that my door will always
be open to you we might not always agree
but I will always give you a fair
hearing and I will seek to address your
concerns wherever possible all three of
the missions that I'm sending out today
depend on the thriving business sector
in Scotland so the government I lead
will do everything we can to help you to
prosper
the third and last of our missions which
is based on community is to focus on the
delivery of key public services for
example the NHS and social care schools
and child care the police and Justice
and public transport the NHS in the last
three years has faced the greatest
Challenge and it's 74 year existence
staff have performed magnificently in
the face of the pandemic that we will
invest in the NHS to help it recover
from the pandemic so that over the next
three years at waiting lists will fall
the outcomes for cancer treatment will
improve will continue to support Primary
Care we'll invest more in general
practice particularly in the most
disadvantaged areas of the country we
will also improve Mental Health and
Welfare support will secure better
access to NHS Dentistry we're also
committed to improving social care
services and reducing delayed discharge
I know well the workforce challenges
that the adult social care sector in
particular faces and that is why I will
commit to a timetable that sets out how
this government will get to 10 pounds an
hour for adult social care workers well
we're not able to afford to do this
absolutely immediately I want to send a
signal to the sector that we are
absolutely serious about improving pay
about improving terms and conditions for
those who care for our most vulnerable
and a key way of improving consistency
of cares of course through the national
Care Service in a way that commands
consensus amongst our key Partners
including trade unions including local
government yesterday I confirmed that we
would ask and seek from Parliament and
extension to the scrutiny process for
the legislation that will help us to
build that consensus the aim of the
national Care Service legislation
ensuring that consistently high standard
of care right across the country is one
which attracts wide support my hope is
that by taking slightly more time to
agree a way forward we can ensure that
we agree and Achieve that aim we'll also
continue to ensure that staff in our
Health and Care Services are valued and
they're fairly paid as things stand
Scotland is the only part of the UK
where no NHS worker has gone on strike
during the last year that's something
I'm proud of and I'm grateful for the
Scottish government will soon enter into
talks with Junior doctors in the hope of
arriving at a fair settlement for them
and as well as supporting our NHS and
care services we'll also continue to
invest in other key public services in
the justice system the backlog of court
cases caused by that pandemic is already
decreasing it will continue to fall
during the next three years we'll
continue to implement important
improvements in our justice system such
as better handling of cases involving
sexual offenses we will improve child
care for school-aged children Alex
accelerate the expansion of child care
for one and two-year-olds we'll continue
to focus on closing
the poverty related attainment Gap in
schools while raising the attainment for
all will improve experiences and
outcomes for children for young people
and their families who use amid that
additional support for learning and as
part of our efforts to improve school
education we'll increase the
availability of internationally
comparable data on Scotland's
educational performance
Scotland already participates in the
widely respected Pisa studies we also
know that we will also now apply to
rejoin two major International statistic
systems trains in international Master
science and progress in international
reading literacy
we'll also make our public transport
system more accessible we'll make it
more available we'll make it more
affordable and as an important part of
that I can confirm today that the
six-month pilot to remove Peak peak time
fares from squat rail will start in
October of this year the evidence of
this pilot and a wider fairs review will
allow us to bring forward further
targeted measures from next year onwards
to ensure the cost of Transport are more
fairly shared and as part of that
commitment to active travel we'll also
ensure our investment to deliver more
places where people can walk where they
can wheel and cycle safely for
day-to-day Journeys increases we'll
double the charge Point Network for
electric vehicles to at least six
thousand and increase the number of zero
emission buses on Scotland's roads we'll
deliver six new major vessels to serve
Scotland's Ferry Network
the final point that I want to highlight
here is that local government is a vital
partner in delivering the services that
all of us rely on WE intend to agree and
Implement a new deal for local
government to help us to work together
more effectively part of that is about
giving us giving local authorities far
more discretion on sources of funding as
we have previously confirmed subject to
parliament's approval we will legislate
to give councils the power to apply a
local visitor Levy in overnight stays
and as we launch a consultation
yesterday on measures which will give
local authorities additional powers to
increase the rate of council tax in
second and empty properties the
consultation also seeks views on
altering the threshold for self-catering
accommodation to qualify for
non-domestic rights the Constitution has
come about as a result of effective
joint working between the Scottish
government and local government and I
hope it demonstrates the local
authorities that we see them as an
essential partner in helping to achieve
Ambitions for Scotland in years to come
in conclusion planning officer when I
was elected as party leader I promised
that I would never pretend that
government is easier is not I would not
offer empty promises in the face of
really difficult challenges the document
we're publishing today sets out our
determination to honor that commitment
it is built on the idea of working in
partnership with business with trade
unions with local government with our
third sector and of course our green
colleagues in government
that recognizes the financial
constraints we operate under it's
realistic about the social the economic
the environmental challenges we face but
that realism is also balanced by
optimism about our ability to meet those
challenges Scotland is a land of
opportunity I'm very proud of that fact
I'm proud to be a product of that my
grandparents came to this country in the
1960s barely speaking English little
money in their pockets despite the
challenges they faced and at times
hostility they faced due to their
background they overcame those barriers
and provided life for their children and
for their grandchildren that I will I
will forever be grateful for it's my
responsibility as first minister to
ensure every family in Scotland has that
equality of opportunity regardless of
the background or where they live in
Scotland I'm optimistic we can achieve
that equality of opportunity and the
three missions that I have set out today
will determine the priorities of the
government that I lead for the rest of
this parliamentary session and help us
to achieve that together we will be
delivered focused on the delivery we
will ensure that we have an affordable
ambitious measures in place which
protect our environment which protect
business Prosperity they improve
people's well-being and they reduce
poverty they will ensure the actions we
take over the next three years stand
Scotland in good stead for the next
decade to come and they will use our
present very significant strengths to
deliver a fresh start for Scotland
thank you
the first Municipal note take questions
on the issues raised in his statement I
intend to allow around 40 minutes for
questions after which time we will move
on to the next item of business and it
would be helpful if those members who
would wish to ask a question were to
press the requisite speak button and I
call on Megan Gallagher
presiding officer the first Minister
makes this statement today as Scandal
continues to engulf his party the SMP is
in total meltdown it's former Chief
Executive and now its current Treasurer
have been arrested amid a police
investigation into the party's finances
and leaked footage has shown Nicholas
surgeon trying to shut down scrutiny
mere months before the investigation
began
is so indebted to his former mentors
that he will not do the right thing and
suspend them while the investigation is
ongoing
as past time that harms the use of
tackled this Scandal head-on and proved
to the Scottish public that he has his
own man instead of Defending and
deflecting from his predecessors
tarnished Legacy
turning to the substance of Hamza
yusuf's statement
we welcome the decision to u-turn on 13
years of SNP education policy and
rejoined International School league
tables
report that this is just the beginning
of a wholesale re-evaluation of how this
government has devalued Scottish
education over its time in office
yet as a whole hundred years of
proposals does nothing to dispel the
notion that has he is a continuity first
Minister leading a continuity government
thinking around with Nicholas Sergeant's
failing policy agenda and continuing to
be led by the extremist greens instead
of delivering the fresh leadership
Scotland needs right now and it will
just me the majority of the Scottish
public that campaigning for Independence
is the top priority for Hamza Yusuf at a
time in Scotland these National
leadership focus on tackling the big
challenges we all face a global cost of
living crisis and NHS on its knees
thanks to this first Minister and a
sluggish economy we have a nationalist
leader continuing to appeal to his
hopelessly divided party
so can I ask a can I ask the first
Minister on the commitments he makes in
his threadbear document whether anyone
seriously believes that this government
will close the attainment gap by the end
of this Parliament secondly on the
deposit return scheme we welcome the
delay which is a humiliation for the
green Minister Lorna Slater but can the
first Minister can the first Minister
promise the Scottish government will
um will engage with businesses on the
deposit return scheme which they failed
to do so so far and finally given the
Scandal engulfing his party can the
first Minister tell me whether the SNP
remains in debt to Peter model and when
it intends to repay that loan
I am first Minister and I should respond
to the questions within your first
ministerial responsibilities thank you
yeah indeed can I can I talk about the
issues which I think are of importance
to this people of Scotland and what I
would say to what I would say to Megan
Gallagher is awfully awfully Brave to
talk about a global course of learning
crisis we're dealing with the Tory
Westminster crisis
that is why
the year the most recent IMF projections
project that the UK government in fact
an outlier the lowest growth of any G7
economy that's a total cost of living
crisis that's a union dividend Scotland
definitely doesn't need and you should
own that as opposed uh to trying to
deflect away from it uh presiding
officer what I would say is of course we
have listened to Scottish business and
Loan us later we'll give further updates
to the package of measures around the
DRS scheme that we're bringing for but
let's be honest uh presiding uh officer
all of us talk about the need to tackle
the climate emergency
I really we need to hear the first
Minister respond to the questions that
Ms Gala had raised first Minister we are
the ones who not only talk the talk we
are prepared to walk the walk and when
it comes to the conservatives every time
we bring forward a measure on the the
claimant emergency they are the first
ones to oppose it time and time again so
they're not serious designing officer
they are not serious at all about
tackling the climate emergency so we'll
continue to talk and of course engage
with not just business but with the
Scottish public about the priorities uh
that they have and may I say to Megan
Gallagher it is uh Brave some may use
another word for it when it comes to
talking about prior propriety your prime
minister your Deputy Prime Minister and
the former prime minister are all under
investigation by the Standards
Commission so yes so yes well while we
Face challenges
well we absolutely face challenges I'd
rather be standing here with the
opportunity to deliver for the people of
Scotland rather than languishing in the
opposition like Megan Gallagher and the
Scottish stories
before I call the next MSP we if we
continue to make Such Noise We cannot
hear any of the answers and I think that
would be unfortunate I call anisawa
thank you presenting officer some of the
announcements in the first Minister
statement today are welcome some of it
is undoubtedly well-intentioned but much
of it is rehashed promises from the past
that have never been delivered but what
happens to Yusuf can't escape from is
that he is not now running a functioning
government this is an SMP that is mired
in Scandal mired in division talking to
themselves about themselves and the
crisis that now engulfs the SNP is not
just an indication of how they govern
their party but also how they govern our
country
16-year culture of command and control
of Financial mismanagement and a lack of
transparency meaning secrecy and
cover-ups often with devastating
consequences and no amount of spin or
the pretense of a reset or a fresh start
is going to hide what is now becoming
clearer to the public every single day
our country is now crying out for
leadership for Hope for new ideas and a
new vision to confront the trend crises
our nation faces a cost of living crisis
with families struggling to pay the
bills and an NHS crisis with patients
struggling to access life-saving
treatment continuity won't cut it
incompetence has consequences and
frankly Scotland deserves better but it
doesn't need to be like this this isn't
as good as it gets change is possible we
can have a government that that was the
cost of living crisis and brings down
bills we can have a government that
grows the economy and invests in the
opportunities of the future we can have
a government that can restore and renew
our NHS and we can have a government the
people's priorities first but after just
three weeks in office isn't it already
clear that it can't be this first
minister or this SMP government
Christmas
goodness not a single not a single idea
not a single proposal not a single bet
of understanding of the policy
prospectus completely vacuous from the
master of the sound bite no no substance
no substance at all all style and no
substance whatsoever from Anna Sawa
because he is vacuous completely devoid
of any policy proposals that of his own
whatsoever and he says the Scottish
government in the last 16 years hasn't
achieved anything what we've achieved is
the game-changing Scottish child payment
which has helped 385
000 children under the age of 16 who are
now eligible we've established new
public services including of course
Social Security Scotland based on
fairness dignity and respect is
delivering 13 benefits seven of them
only available available here in
Scotland we've delivered the baby box
we've abolished tuition fees of course
the back door tuition fees were
something that were brought in by the
Scottish labor party we've abolished
prescription charges we've made sure
that care is Free Flow Free for All when
it comes to free personal and nursing
care we have now three bus travel for
over 2 million people for those who are
under 22 for people with disabilities
with those over the age of 60 we've
built 118
000 uh affordable homes we funded child
care we have the most generous offer of
child care here in Scotland compared to
anywhere else in the UK and of course
the difference between anasawar and I is
that when it comes to Authority cost of
living crisis he wants to keep the
powers in the hands of the conservatives
I want to ensure this Parliament has all
the financial and economic levers to
tackle that cost of living Christ this
and he says Anna Sawa says the people of
Scotland are crying out for change what
we don't need what we don't need
is a replacement of one Tory government
with a pale imitation of a Tory
government with here starmer even Anna
Sawa even Anna Sawa must be embarrassed
I know certainly Richard Leonard will be
and oh and sarbar must be embarrassed by
Kier sawar appealing to the right with
his anti-refugee
anti-immigration rhetoric his inability
to stand up for the most marginalized
and we know we know that it's only with
the powers of Independence will we get
rid of Tory governments in Scotland for
good
[Applause]